and just a few moments ago wilmer defoe
a little sammy sosa action
for will crow looking for a second major
league win
this will be his
13th appearance his 12th start but so
far so good for him as this ball is
poked into right center for the first
braves hit ozzy serves one big turn he's
trying for two here comes the throw it's
gonna be late
hustle double for ozzy albee's his 24th
two base hit of the year
well great job by ozzy you see
even a 12 35 game i'll tell you chip
i'll be honest most guys are hitting
that ball nice easy run to first base
with a turn and not ozzy 15th pitch for
will crow coming up three balls two
strikes here it is
and riley unloads high in the air toward
shallow center that's going to drop for
a hit and ozzy albee's running at the
crack of the bat is going to score the
game's first run
right he didn't hit it hard he hit it
high and in a right spot and the braves
break through with the two out hit boy
do they need that yeah kind of break
open the floodgates hopefully here in
the first at least give them some
breathing room
should be the final out frasier
falls off nagowski that does it so two
odd action for the braves
hustling double for albie's riley brings
him home pirates come to bat and
hopefully the pirates will say we've
seen enough of drew smiley because jeff
as you said he is on his best role as a
brave right now yeah as we said you see
the first eight starts compared to the
last six obviously a huge thing you see
chip keeping the ball in the yard
another line shot toward right center
field by key brian hayes heads to the
wall cut off by heredia cora holds
frazier hayes
is back
so much fun to see
that bad path
nothing in one for reynolds
and that's pope dansby swanson good play
they're coming home on contact that's
going to be an easy out
wow thank you very much good smart heads
up play by swanson who jeff in the last
week has made at least three of those
plays at shortstop well twofold here the
play obviously was great that ball was
hit hard but the throw on the run a
little bit to be able to hit the catcher
in stride well now first and second with
one out and he got stallings up
that's clump toward right center field
already on his horse toward the wall and
out of here
jacob stallings clears the deck
a cannonball to turn things around after
the play by swanson
number six for the cheetah my goodness
jacob stallings the oppo pop
gets an elevated i believe an elevated
fastball
wow up and out over the plate that's a
stunning reversal
the line drive but right at riley
another hard hit ball will crow almost
cleared the bases pittsburgh sends nine
to the plate and they score three after
one
crow
it's heredia
perfect spot for that breaking ball
nice work
strikes out smiley leadoff hit swanson
stranded 3-1 pirates atlanta's rbi a
base hit from austin riley in the first
inning a two-out single
there's a drive hammered and crow knows
that one's not coming back
way out of here and left and ronald
lacuna has his 24th home run
and the braves are now down three to two
now this pitch was over the plate and up
and for him without power that ball was
absolutely crushed in the left field
seats acuna now one behind kyle
schwarber of the nationals
three behind tatis
his sights over there
that ball is crushed toward left oliver
going back at the track at the wall it's
off the fence riley on his way to second
he's got to hustle in with a double
anyplace else he's making the grand tour
instead he'll stand at second with a two
out double smiley looks for a one two
three inning he walked oliver
intentionally to get to will crow to
load the bases in the first and oliver
with a fly ball toward pacuna
approaching the wall
and off the wall all of us showing some
opposite field pop
a double off the wall and right for
jared oliver
oh my gosh this guy's crazy good
i was just gonna ask is anybody hang in
there against lefties from the left side
as
good as frasier
it's crazy it really is
and there goes frazier for third base
how about that
surprise attack from frazier two balls
no strikes
and lifted to
the left side ozzy will be retired got
word that ozzy albies was taken out of
the game he was removed with tightness
in his neck
precautionary holmes was able to get
arcia in the sixth inning on monday
holmes pitched a one two three
and a swinging strikeout
klay holm strands two
we have reached the halfway mark in the
final game of the series and the pirates
are leading by one
and smiley gets a swing in the miss
back-to-back strikeouts pittsburgh
strands two more they're one for 12 with
renders in scoring position but still
lead second and third one out
and abraham almante will pinch it
first pitch swing and he uses the
opposite field that's going to score a
couple of runs almante off the bench
with an rbi single the braves cash in
the two walks and jump in front four to
three and here it is
a basis loaded walk
that will score
almonte
that run belongs to kyle crick so arcia
bats he's the ninth man to come up 5-3
braves
a bullet hitting the left field that's a
base hit that's going to score a couple
more the braves finally taking some
frustrations out on the pirates bullpen
garcia a two-run scoring single smiley
allowed three runs in the first no runs
after that
and frazier a hot smash is speared by
riley diving to his right
wow he doesn't catch it that's extra
bases
great job and riley's been peppered this
entire series with line drives a third
that was a beauty it is an official game
already
and tom hallian's going to say enough
big raindrops
maybe some lightning too
and the braves will run for cover here
as we have
a rain delay at approximately 35 eastern
time and after
an hour and i'll call it 17-minute rain
delay
we're back in action
and he got him he pulled a string
and aj minter retires frazier and the
pirates strand three more after seven
oh
oh great play by frazier
robs riley riley got him earlier and uh
frazier didn't look too happy about it
on a line drive to third
and uh riley hits this one good
it's up just enough heck of a play
and now ender lifts one high in the air
deep toward right back into that
scoreboard it's high off the wall late
break by adrianza he's on his way to
third and he's going to stop there
ander with a double off the wall and now
adrianza will come home and score as the
ball gets away in the middle infield 8-3
atlanta let's see if dansby can pick up
an rbi here
this one hit the air toward right center
field still going and that ball is off
the wall
streaking around third is ender he's
going to score and the hitting has
become contagious all of a sudden for
the braves it's down nine to three
off the middle there's a base hit for
lucoy here comes dansby around third he
is going to score so welcome to atlanta
jonathan abraham almonte is the batter
that ball is hammered toward right
center field that ball is gone a line
drive homer for almonte
bombs away for the braves
it's a dirty dozen for the atlanta
offense 12-3 as you score
another bullet this one into right
center field as well
acuna is going to score freeman's going
to come around
and he's going to score without a throw
[Music]
and dwayne underwood is taking some
pirate punishment here in the eighth
enemy in a 14-3 game john nakowski
oh look at him jeffy looks like a crafty
sidewinder his first career pitching
appearance looks like maybe colin
moran's glove and nagowski
one he can feel his position how about a
scoreless inning
for the big nagowski
great did it quick
and races off he's got a bat now
ohtani
and this ought to do it shallow right
acuna comes charging in and the braves
have won it
it is a 14-3 final score